rainbow six extraction takes the
framework of rainbow six siege a pvp
game and reimagines it in a pve setting
with three people working as a team to
defeat the alien threat known as the
arkians while a lot of your rainbow six
siege skills will transfer over it is
also quite different in a number of key
ways which is why after playing the game
for over 20 hours we have 15 tips to
help you out when you first start
rainbow six extraction and if you find
these tips useful why not hit the like
and sub button it really helps us out a
lot okay so probably the most important
thing when it comes to rainbow six
whether it's siege or extraction is your
teamwork i don't know about you but i
never like playing rainbow six siege
with randos i always play with a
personal party of close friends that i
know and that goes doubly so for
extraction with siege at least you can
just rely on your brandos being good at
shooting people but with extraction you
have to constantly be communicating due
to the objective based nature of the
game like yeah you can solo but i
wouldn't recommend it okay but say you
do want to play some and your friends
aren't available so i'm gonna hop into
the solo queue you're gonna need to talk
with a headset the pings are okay but
they're not gonna cut it so either get
used to talking on the mic with randos
or only play with your friends and
that's because communication starts
right away on the operator select screen
so every round of extraction is called
an incursion and every incursion is
broken up into three sub zones each with
randomly generated objectives
at the start of an incursion you can see
each objective very clearly and certain
operators are better for certain
objectives for example if you want to
locate tech objects you want to pick iq
or if you need to sneak up and stealth
kill particular archians this can be
done with stealth characters like vigil
the key is to spend a moment and talk
with your team look at your objectives
see what you need and make sure all the
roles are being properly filled a big
part of this game is leveling up your
overall career it's how you unlock new
operators new maps and new equipment
playing on higher difficulties does
improve the rewards and the xp you gain
but the best way to boost up your levels
are the games studies which are
extractions versions of map specific
in-game challenges each map has several
pages of challenges and each page
features three studies you'll need to
complete the current page you're on
before you can unlock the next page of
objectives and there's no way to change
them so you're kind of just stuck with
whatever objective you currently have if
you want to be leveling up at a
consistent pace it's important to be
focusing on these studies now the
problem with this is that studies can
require you to do things that may be
misaligned with your current objective
the reality is sometimes you might just
have to go rogue and do your own thing
and only care about yourself but if
you're playing with friends the best
thing to do is just communicate with
each other and decide hey we're going
specifically into this incursion just to
focus on these studies and then get back
out we did this plenty of times
throughout our play and we found we were
able to level up pretty consistently
speaking of studies sometimes they will
call for killing very particular types
of argens this can be a little bit
frustrating because what archaeans spawn
on the map is randomized so there's no
way to go into a map guaranteeing that
you will find that particular arcane
that you need for the study however you
can improve your chances by playing on
harder difficulties for example there
are some enemy types that just straight
up will not spawn on the base moderate
difficulty so if you're trying to find
say tormentors on alaska don't play on
moderate difficulty play on at least
cautious to guarantee that some
tormentors might show up and from there
with each difficulty it just increases
the chances of these more rare types of
archaeans showing up another key to a
successful extraction is good nest
management nests are the glowing spores
from which virtually all of these
sub-zones archaeans spawn from and each
subzone begins with these nest line
dormant the trick specifically on higher
difficulties is to employ stealth by
taking out nests quietly you'll avoid
stirring them into spawning many more
archaeans once an archaean spots you
it'll perform a shrieking scream that
will alert nearby nests permanently
activating them with a more steady
stream of archaeans spawning out it's
rarely a good idea to go into an
incursion guns blazing you want to start
stealthing as much as possible this
means there's pretty much no reason not
to have a silencer attached of course
you should always be performing stealthy
melee takedowns to save on ammo
especially on harder difficulties where
ammo is at a premium take the time to
look at the attachments on your
operator's weapons and put on silencers
whenever possible of course this is
rainbow six so there might be times when
you need to use a big hulk and shotgun
to blast a hole through a wall we found
this tactic to be not quite as necessary
as it is in siege however there are
times where we found ourselves doing
this either to avoid a certain group of
enemies get to an objective faster or
make a quick escape something cool to
note is that in extraction you have a
special flashlight affixed to the front
of your gun at all times that can
actually let you see aliens through
breakable walls this is a great way to
be able to identify archians easily and
shoot them through the walls without
ever putting yourself in danger
a certain video game muscle memory that
you're gonna have to abandon when
playing extraction is the idea that you
need to always push through no matter
what an extraction is often better to
extract early and save yourself a lot of
headache
sometimes a run just goes wrong allies
die you lose a significant chunk of your
health and realistically you don't think
you're gonna make it to the end if
that's the way you're feeling cut out
early if you end up dying you will lose
that operator as well as a good chunk of
your progression xp and you won't get it
back until you go rescue them also you
get a pretty large xp bonus if you
extract with your full squad so going
the rest of the way solo might not net
you as much xp as it would extracting
with your full party another important
thing is to manage your resource
supplies resources come in the forms of
react gear abilities ammo and health and
all of them are very important to keep
full up when you bring up the map menu
you actually have a live tracker of how
many resource caches are left in the
active subzone you're in always double
check this if you're looking for
something like a health kit so you're
not wasting time looking for something
that might not even be there and of
course because these are limited you do
want to make sure you're sharing them
with your teammate the reality is
especially on earlier difficulties you
don't need all that ammo but your ally
might so it's always good to just
communicate with everybody and make sure
everyone is topped up and has everything
they need if finding resource caches is
a big priority for your team make sure
to have someone play as iq whose ability
lets you easily find them you can also
point out resource caches using the ping
system i said before that the ping
system isn't a replacement for mics and
that is true but you should still be
just pinging everything all the time
ping enemies ping spores ping resource
caches ping ping ping okay here's like a
really quick tip that's just kind of
nice to know whenever you're moving
along to the next sub zone you need to
have two players activate it in order
for it to start counting down however
that countdown is 30 seconds if you just
want to speed things up have the third
player come in and also activate it and
it will switch to a 5 second countdown
this can be incredibly useful if the
extraction zone is hot and you're trying
to get out of there asap or you're just
looking to speed things along if you
want to make an objective easier in this
game the key is to spend as much time
scouting the surrounding area of the
objective as possible that means killing
arcanes and destroying nests there are
certain objectives that will alert
nearby nests and they will start
spawning archians in so if you destroy
them beforehand it'll make things a lot
easier for you
if you're ever trying to do a mission
where you're rescuing an operator a way
to make it really easy is just to go
around the area of the archaean tree and
destroy all the little nests when you
actually activate the rescue attempt it
doesn't spawn more arcane so as long as
you destroyed all the nests you should
be able to save them without any extra
stress something you'll have to worry
about throughout this game is sprawl
which is the
gross goo that just covers the entire
map archaeans spawn it nest spawn it it
can be a real pain because you move
slower and sprawl and archaeans move
faster and can sometimes do more damage
in sprawl it gets even worse on harder
difficulties where you can get a
mutation where sprawl turns green and
becomes poisonous so how do you manage
sprawl first off always kill enemies in
their weak points when you kill an enemy
normally they actually leave sprawl
behind when they die but if you kill
them in their weak point they do not
leave down sprawl arcane weak points are
pretty obvious it's the pink glowish hue
that you can see on their body so just
aim for that and you should be fine of
course what do you do when you already
have sprawl to deal with there is a cool
laser tool you can get that can remove
sprawl for you but you don't get that
until level 25 which is a long ways out
instead you just want to shoot it or
melee it although melee is very very
slow so probably just shoot it having
full mobility is a huge plus so it's
really important that you take the time
to shoot all the sprawl before you start
an objective or to help create a path
for a planned route that you need to
take and really that kind of sums up the
whole ethos around this game it's about
scouting things out in advance planning
your routes planning your objectives and
then acting accordingly if you play
smart and communicate with your team you
will be knocking out incursions like
nobody's business and having a pretty
fun time doing it but of course there's
probably some tips we missed so if you
have any advice to give to your fellow
rainbow six players throw them down in
the comments below and thanks for
watching